one of the most remarkable and troubling
moments in the years long Russia saga
occurred you may remember when the
former deputy FBI director Andy McCabe
claimed the deputy AG rod Rosenstein had
offered to wear a wire to spy on the
president now at the time Rosen's I
denied it today though Judicial Watch
announced it had obtained a two-page
memo from May of 2017 in which McCabe
records Rosen Stein making that offer
according to the memo Rosen Stein
thought he could sneak a wire in because
he was not searched when visiting the
White House Matthew Whitaker was acting
Attorney General under President Trump
enjoins us now mr. Ricca thanks very
much for coming on what do you make of
this report well the memo in and of
itself is extraordinary because it
captures a moment in time between the
firing of Jim Comey and the appointment
of the special counsel and it and it
really to some extent lays out the
entire conversations that Andy McCabe is
acting deputy as Acting FBI director had
with with DEP Deputy Attorney General
Rosen Stein and others
and I just think it's extraordinary that
they were having a discussion whether or
not it was a joke as I've heard
Rosenstein allege of wearing a wire into
the White House into the Oval Office and
recording the president it's just it is
I can't imagine under what circumstance
that conversation would have come up and
would have would have had been had
between those two people so I mean
you've worked at this level of
government for a long time assess the
likelihood that it was quote a joke well
so at the time I was the chief of staff
when when when when Rosenstein issued
that extraordinary statement and then
another statement on top of that when
the first one wasn't received well and
and the story was covered by by many and
and it was obviously the only
explanation that he could have stayed in
that role if it had been a serious
consideration of wearing a wire in the
Oval Office then obviously the president
couldn't have the trust and confidence
and Roz who hid he had to explain it as
being a joke and saying that as a
facetious matter up I don't know I think
I know there were others in that same
meeting that also took copious notes
I would expect yes that since tom Fitton
and his groups that do such a good job
that we will see those contemporary US
notes as well because i think we're far
from over but the prosecutor in me wants
to corroborate this story and andy
mccabe at the time had a lot of reasons
to write down historically inaccurate
accounts because he was about he had
just put the president into this
investigation as a target so I guess the
obvious question is do you think and you
know him Rudd Rosenstein is capable of
that I don't you know I worked
side-by-side with was with rod as Deputy
Attorney General when I was acting
Attorney General I also worked when I
was chief of staff I I would be
surprised if he had honestly said that
he would wear a wire but at the same
time if you read that memo it's very
clear that Andy McCabe didn't think rod
was joking and I would like to see what
others in the room thought because I was
not in the room at the time and I think
it would be it is something that I just
think is so extraordinary even be
talking about wearing a wire
whether you're joking or not that I
think we need a few more witnesses to
that conversation to actually know
whether rod was joking or not but it's
just extraordinary yeah I think so too
Matthew Whitaker thanks so much for that